general Soleimani fought heroically
against Isis al-nusrah and al-qaida he
says if it weren't for his war on terror
European capitals would be great in
great danger now he continues our final
answer to his assassination will be to
kick all US forces out of the region
well that was a message echoed by
foreign minister Javad Zarif he
emphasized that Iran's next steps will
depends on the reaction from the US
we've said very clearly that if the
United States takes any further action
Iran will respond accordingly and we
will respond in a very harsh way but
proportionately well we did not start
this process of escalation the United
States waged an economic war against
Iran the United States has to come to
its senses the presence of Iranian
people in the streets of many cities
unprecedented in the history Europe can
play a useful role by informing the
United States of the serious error in
their analysis that they should stop
listening to clowns that they should
base their policy based on realities and
not some illusions of some clowns who
have ambitions elsewhere well let's to
head to Tehran where daughter Jabari has
been standing by at door so have been
hearing lots of reaction out of Tehran
and reaction to those strikes at what
else have you been hearing
well the foreign minister we just heard
from was at the weekly cabinet meeting
we've also heard from the defense
minister Matata me who expressed his
views he said that the Revolutionary
Guards carried out what they was their
duty essentially he thanked them for
their service he also said that this is
a just the beginning is just the start
of Iran's response we also heard from
the president of his cabinet meeting he
said that the revenge that's coming for
the Americans is really this is just the
beginning he said that the awesome
soleimani hand was cut off during the
attack which killed him
now it's time to cut off the legs of the
United States in the region in the
Middle East he said that the price that
they will pay for killing Qasem
Soleimani is they have to leave this
entire region altogether we've also just
had a tweet from the Supreme Leader's
account on Twitter where he says that
this slap in the face last night is not
enough that this military action that
Iran carried out by attacking the US
military base in Iraq is not enough so
we are getting indications that what
happened is just the start of what is to
come unfortunately in this conflict that
has now really exploded between the
United States and Iran and the latest
developments just indicates that there
is more to come between the two sides in
this region okay don't say Jabari for
now thank you or Twitter of course
president Trump's preferred form of
communication let's get more now from
Gabriel Elizondo he's live in Washington
DC Gabe
first reaction from the president
responding on Twitter that all is well
what can we read into this yeah that was
the only statement we've heard from the
White House or President Trump since 10
hours now and that that's when that
tweet came out all is good so far so
good as he said I think what we can read
into that is really one thing is that
that tweet came out after he met with
his War Cabinet Secretary of Defense
Secretary of State Joint Chiefs of Staff
and the immediate aftermath of the
attack in Iraq I think that what this
tweet by the Trezza dn't basically is is
basically a pause he wants to pause
right now on the situation slip on it
throughout the evening no American
troops were killed I think that was very
critical I think if American troops were
killed we'd probably be having a much
different conversation right now
although his tweet from late Tuesday is
probably less important than what we're
going to hear from President Trump in
the coming hours it is a little after
7:00 a.m. here in Washington DC it's
been quiet throughout the evening but
expect that to change very soon we're
expected that Trump is expected either
release a statement or make some sort of
press conference or address the
situation of the missile strikes at some
point in the coming hours here Wednesday
morning in DC what he says will be
absolutely critical
it is his moment perhaps either to be a
little conciliatory and maybe indicate
that he will be taking a more diplomatic
path or we could get a sense of he might
be with more of his bellicose language
maybe indicate that he you will open the
door to retaliating again against Iran
we just simply have no idea so that'll
be critical we'll are also going to be
watching two other things in Washington
this morning number one is more
information from the Pentagon we've
heard no information throughout the
evening on exactly what their damage
assessment was on what kind of damage
was done to any military infrastructure
on those two bases so we expect to hear
from the Pentagon also key members of
Congress might be briefed by
administration officials on the attack
at some point this morning as well so we
might get more information there well
speaking of the members of Congress and
what sort of reaction have we been
hearing from those around the president
we know the Secretary of State and the
Defense Secretary say they both want to
de-escalate this crisis are they all
speaking with one voice well they did
say they want to de-escalate the
situation but they said that earlier on
Tuesday before the missile strikes and
so we have not heard from them
since then we also did not hear from a
lot of members of Congress either after
the missile strikes took place probably
because it was a little late in the
evening on Tuesday by the time pretty
much all ended however we did hear from
Lindsey Graham a very hawkish anti-iran
member of Senate of the Senate who was
also a very close adviser to president
Donald Trump listen closely what he had
to say
late Tuesday night the missiles were
launched from Iran at targets inside of
Iraq housing US military personnel the
president has all the authority needs
under article 2 to respond and high
responses yet to be determined
but he has that authority to respond it
was an act of war by regime for the last
40 years it's been a cancer in the
Mideast when they say they want to
destroy Israel they're not kidding
they're the largest state sponsor of
terrorism now Trump is probably going to
have two groups of people whispering in
his ear on one side you're gonna have
people probably such as Lindsey Graham
encouraging the president to strike back
again to retaliate again against Iran
and to strike something there that's
that's one side that you just heard
you're probably also gonna hear Trump
will probably also hear from some other
advisors saying this is the perfect
opportunity to take the off-ramp and
pursue some point of diplomacy and to
de-escalate the situation what will
Trump decide what's in his head
what will he announce we simply do not
know all we know is that he's a very
unpredictable president and we should
get a better idea about what he's he's
thinking and where this goes from here
when he speaks in the coming hours and
when we get that we will of course cross
back to you and the team in Washington
DC but for now Gabriel Elizondo
thank you